King Charles officially removes his
younger brother prince Andrew from
Buckingham Palace I think you know the
Royal Family well they've cut Andrew off
from public duties they've ever
live but I think a lot of people are
saying well you know that's not enough
he needs to answer those allegations and
now the king is taking action back in
2019 the Duke of York stepped back from
his Royal duties and was stripped of his
hrh titles amid his controversial
connection to disgraced billionaire
Jeffrey Epstein who died in jail that
same year there is a lot of suggestion
that actually it was the queen who
pretty much forced prince Andrew to step
down after a series of intensive crisis
talks with the Prince of Wales I think
they both realized that Andrew's
position was untenable and there was no
choice but for him to step back from
Royal duties fast forward to 2023 and a
royal Insider tells E.T prince Andrew
will no longer have use of his plush
Suite of rooms at the palace which
housed his Royal apartment and office
because King Charles removed his access
from that section The Insider adds that
it's shocking Andrew was able to keep
the Royal digs for as long as he did we
are going to have the reign of King
Charles III he's not going to waste any
time getting to our pretty quickly but
despite the reports that the Duke has
been evicted ET has learned he wasn't
using the sweets in fact he's still
living at the Royal Lodge at Windsor
with his ex-wife Sarah Ferguson whom he
shares two daughters with princesses
Beatrice and Eugenie he is incredibly
close to both of his daughters you'll
notice that neither Beatrice or Eugenie
have come out to say anything about the
case they are standing in solidarity
with their father our Royal Insider also
shares that Andrew's security has also
been a point of contention why because
he's maintained his security detail
while King Charles's son Prince Harry
and daughter-in-law Meghan Markle were
stripped of theirs when they stepped
down as senior Royals in 2021 given the
fact that they are two of the most
famous people on the planet and I think
it's fair to say quite divisive people I
think absolutely they have a case in
point for security a lot of people here
believe that because they're not working
Royals they're not entitled to
taxpayer-funded security they've made
plenty of millions of their our own they
should be spending that on their private
security it's unclear how Andrew's Royal
Security will be handled in the future
and as far as Andrew's Royal launch stay
goes our Insider says there's no plan to
evict him from those living quarters at
least for now